GAVIN KINGHALL WERE: So vitals
was the most requested session
here at Playtime today.
So we're going to kind of assume
that you all know about vitals.
And we're going to tell you
what we've been up to recently.
Also, we're going to go into
a bit more detail about what
Tian announced earlier.
And then Fergus is
going to come up,
and he's going to tell
you a little bit more
about why you should really,
really care about your vitals.
So first thing, I made
a bit of an assumption
that you do all know about
your Android vitals, right?
Can I get a show of
hands maybe, everybody
who's using Android vitals?
Not bad, but I can
see quite a few here
that didn't put their hands up.
So just for you and
your vitals, it's
15 engineering metrics covering
five different performance
areas that really give you
insight into the things
that users care about the most.
So it represents the performance
and quality of your app
as experienced by real users on
real devices in the real world.
And most importantly,
it gives you,
as business leaders,
maybe people
outside of the engineering team,
insight into what is normally
just an engineering metric.
It gives you a very
great, brilliant overview,
I suppose, of what are the main
quality issues that are really
affecting your app, and
perhaps why you're not
seeing the performance
on your business metrics
that you may expect.
But having said that, it's
still really, really important
to recognize that
these are still
engineering quality metrics.
It's up to your engineering
team to actually fix the issues
that vitals identifies.
Therefore, it's
really, really crucial
that your engineering team
actually is using vitals
and is going into
the Play Console
and is looking through
there, going through all
of the metrics that
we have available,
to see what issues
are coming up.
Because those are the
guys that can fix it.
So, for all of those here
who didn't put their hand up
just now, come join the
100,000 developers, including I
think about half, maybe more
than half of the developers
that I saw just now, that
are using vitals already.
So I just want to do a
quick overview of what's
in vitals today,
and a few things
that we launched recently.
And then I'll go into a
bit more detail about what
we're launching today.
So Android vitals is split
into five different performance
areas.
So we have stability,
battery, rendering,
and then since Google I/O,
we added app startup time
and also permissions.
Now, within those five
performance areas,
we have 15 different
metrics for you.
Those metrics are
broken down by at least
three different dimensions.
Now, the set of dimension varies
from one metric to another.
But generally, we have things
like operating system version,
APK version, released tracks,
or whether it is alpha,
beta, or prods.
And then there's a
few other metrics
which are kind of more specific
to a particular-- sorry, a few
more dimensions that are more
specific to particular metrics.
So we have a lot of
data that you can
really, really delve into here.
Let me go into a little bit
more detail about the things
that we launched to I/O as well.
So with app startup
time, we're trying
to help you provide
quick-launching apps.
So across the three different
states that an app may be in,
we want to allow you to measure
how often an app takes too
long to render its first frame.
So from cold start, if it
took 45 seconds or more,
then that will be highlighted
on the first metric.
And same for warm start
and hot start and so forth.
So you know when
the user is waiting
too long to actually get into
your app in the first place.
We also added permissions.
Now, you all know about the
dynamic permission model
that we added not so
long ago to Android.
Now, what we find very
often is that users,
if they are just presented
with a permission dialog--
hey, I want to use
your camera, hey,
I want to use your storage--
and there's no
context for the user,
there's nothing to tell
them why they should grant
the app this permission,
then quite often they'll
go, well, no.
And your app may not then
have the full functionality
that you want that
user to experience.
So this will track how
often your users are denying
the permissions that you
may rely on in your app
to provide the full experience.
So this is why
perhaps you would--
if you have a poor
performance on this metric,
then it's an indicator
that you need
to add that additional
context when you're requesting
permission, so you can actually
provide the value to the user.
What is in it for them?
What's really the reason behind
granting this permission?
We also added
category benchmarks.
Now this is where you can
compare your Android vitals
performance to that
of your competition
within the same category.
So if, for example,
your crash rate is 2%,
and you think, well,
that's kind of OK,
I'm only crashing on
2% of daily sessions.
But then you would look
into the category benchmark,
and you see across your
category, well, actually
all of your
competitors on average,
they're crashing 0.1%, 0.2%,
something much, much lower
than you are.
Then you know that
you are well behind,
and that you need to catch
up with your competition.
We also added anomaly detection.
Now, this is really
really, really powerful.
This will send you an alert
when any of your metrics--
or, excuse me-- four
of your metrics--
app not responding,
crash, excessive wakeup,
and partial background
wakelocks, when they start
trending upwards, or perhaps
even when they're spiking,
maybe you've done a
new release, or you've
enabled a new feature
server side or something,
and, all of a sudden, your crash
rate goes through the roof.
This will send you
an alert so that you
can take action on that as
soon as you possibly can.
It requires you to
go into the console
and sign up for this alert.
Make sure your engineering
teams, in particular,
go and do that, so that
they receive these alerts,
and they can take action before
your users start complaining.
Then the last thing we announced
at Google I/O is core vitals.
Now, there's 15 different
metrics in Android vitals
today.
Now, we identified
some of those that
are particularly important
to the user experience.
These are the ones you
see on the screen here.
So they have crash
rate and ANR rates,
which are from the
stability performance area.
And then partial
background wakelocks
and excessive wakeups,
which are from the battery
sort of resource usage
performance area.
Now, the reason we did this
is because these-- as I said,
these are the ones that are
most important to the user
experience.
Now, there's a lot of metrics.
There are 15.
But these are the ones that
we have prioritized in order
to help you prioritize.
We've also added an additional
piece of information
to each of these metrics,
which we call the bad behavior
threshold.
This is essentially
the line in the sand
for the store as a whole.
If you're below the
bad behavior threshold,
then you can consider your
app to be performing well
on that metric.
And then we have one defined for
each of the core vitals there.
If you're above it, then
that means you've got--
you need to fix that metric.
And you need to do
it pretty quickly.
Now, I wanted to go in
a little bit more detail
as well about what Tian
referred to earlier that we're
launching today.
So this is where we're
linking Android vitals
with pre-launch reports.
Now, pre-launch reports, if
you're not familiar with it,
is a system built into
the Play Console, where
we take your app and
run it on real devices,
sitting in a data center, on
what we call the Firebase Cloud
Test Lab.
And we automatically
navigate through that app
and see what the app does.
We record screenshots.
We record video.
We capture stack
traces if it crashes.
We capture video of it
crashing if it does.
We capture the logs.
And we capture a
lot more metadata
than you will typically
find in Android vitals.
Because vitals is pulling
its data from real users
in the real world, and there's
a lot of privacy implications
of what we can pull
and what we can't.
So if a particular
crash has already
been identified by
pre-launch reports,
then that crash will be linked
to in the Android vitals UI
now.
So you'll have all of that
metadata available to you,
so you can really figure out
much more quickly how to action
and fix that crash
that is occurring.
Similarly, we've updated
pre--launch reports to make
that link in the
other direction also.
If pre-launch reports has
identified a crash that is
actually already happening
on production devices--
as I said, real
users, real world--
then you will see that in the
pre-launch reports UI as well.
So this will allow you to
prioritize the crashes that
have been identified
in pre-launch reports,
and really work on the ones
first that are actually
affecting real users.
So now I want to
hand over to Fergus.
He's going to tell you
a lot more about why
you should really, really
pay attention to your vitals.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
FERGUS HURLEY: Hi, everyone.
My name is Fergus Hurley.
And I'm the product
manager for Android vitals.
Hands up here, who wants more
five-star ratings and less
one-star ratings.
OK.
Hopefully everyone,
unless you're working
for one of your competitors.
And so we learned a lot of
lessons over the last year
from developers who have
actually improved their vitals.
And I'm here to share some of
those lessons with you today.
Feel free to keep your
phones out and take
photos of these lessons.
So we did analysis over all
the reviews on Google Play.
In English.
And what we found
is that when users
are talking about performance
and stability issues,
they talk about them
40% of the time when
they leave a one-star review.
And when people leave
a five-star review,
they're talking about speed,
design, and usability,
over 70% of the time.
So we all know that
performance is important,
and we feel it when
our apps on our phones
don't actually behave correctly.
But here we have
the data to show
how important it is to users.
And if you want to be able
to improve your rating,
you need to be able to focus
on these areas yourself.
As I said, we've been
learning from developers
over the past year,
and developers
have been using our tools.
And as a result,
we've actually seen
improvements in the ecosystem.
So we've seen a
nice bump in users
talking about speed, design,
usability, over the past year
when leaving five-star reviews.
But more importantly, we've
seen a large reduction
of users talking about
stability and bugs
and resource usage, which
includes battery and memory
usage, when leaving
one-star reviews.
Now, let's jump
into some examples
of developers who have been
improving their stability
of their application.
So the team behind "Merge
Dragons," the very popular
Zynga game, was able
to reduce their number
of one-star reviews
by over 50% by being
able to use vitals
to pinpoint issues
within their application.
This enabled them to be able
to boost their user engagement,
while saving their
engineering team a lot of time
in terms of debugging issues.
The Tapps Games team was
able to reduce their ANR rate
by over 80%, because they
were able to pinpoint
a specific set of devices that
were actually having an ANR
issue.
And ANRs are unique
to the Play Console.
This is where your
application is not responding,
and the Android platform
is able to detect that
and is not reported in many
other performance reporting
tools.
And I really encourage
you to check out
the ANR section of
the Play Console,
so you can be able to deliver
a more responsive application
to your users.
Reddit, the very
popular app, was
able to reduce their crash rate
by 75% using Android vitals.
But more importantly,
as a result of the peer
benchmarks that we actually
have available where
you can see how you compare with
other apps in your category,
as Gavin mentioned
earlier, they were
able to understand
that now they're
one of the top applications
out there in terms
of being very stable.
And this enabled them
to be able to share
that data with other people
within their company.
So the engineering team
was able to say, hey, it
was worthwhile for us
to invest in improving
our stability over
the past few months,
because now we're one of the
most stable apps out there.
Another feature that
Gavin mentioned earlier
was anomaly detection.
This is where you
can be able to get
alerted when you have a major
change in the performance
of your application.
The team behind Lovoo had
signed up for anomaly alerts.
And when they had a spike,
which increased their ANR
rate by 94%, they
immediately got
alerted about that
using Android vitals,
and then were able to
disable and add SDK
that was causing that issue.
To be able to work with
that SDK to fix the issue.
And then be able to
release the fixed app that
reduced their ANR rate back
down to its previous level,
and deliver on maximizing
their monetization again.
Now, we don't think you should
give up working on features
and improving the
application in other ways.
But we do think that you can do
focused effort on performance.
And here you can see a
quote from the ABA English
team, which spent
one quarter focusing
on performance improvements.
And that resulted in a 4.6-star
rating for their application.
Obviously, you need
to do more than just
have good vitals to have a
4.6 star rating application.
You need a really
great application.
And we know for sure, though,
that you will never get
a 4.6-star rating app if
you have terrible vitals.
So I've given some great
examples of individual app
developers who have
improved their performance.
We also looked at
the developers who
had engaged most in the Play
Console since Google I/O
amongst our top developers.
And what we found is that they
reduced their crash rate by 50%
over the past few months.
And it is really great
because this results
in a much better experience
for Android end users.
We have 3 billion-plus
active installs
that are much more stable
as a result of this top 10%
of our developers.
So great that these other
developers are having success
using vitals.
Is this really impacting
me and my business?
Well, we looked at apps that
actually have a high crash
rate.
And as Tian mentioned earlier,
users who have a higher crash
rate leave 52% more
one-star ratings
than users with a
lower crash rate,
and 22% more one-star ratings
with a higher ANR rate.
Great.
So that finishes the stability
and bugs side of things.
Now, we're going to move on
to the resource usage side.
So resource usage is battery,
memory, network usage.
And a lot of these
metrics are interrelated.
So one of the metrics
we have on your battery
in the Play Console
Android vitals section
is excessive network use.
Now, this is bad for
end users in two ways.
One is that you're consuming
their data plan, which might be
very expensive for that user.
And two, it consumes their
battery unnecessarily.
The two metrics to pay
most attention to though
in this area are the core
vitals the Gavin mentioned.
The core vitals in battery
being excessive wakeups
and stuck wakelocks
in the background.
The Jaumo team was able to
reduce their excessive wakeup
rate by 70%.
And just look at this
quote for a second here.
So they appreciate the
visibility and diagnostics
tools that Android
vitals provides.
Because very few tools
out there actually
help you be able to understand
how your battery is being used
and uses devices.
And what they say is they
wouldn't have even noticed,
or have been able to fix this
issue, without Android vitals.
So I really encourage
you and your teams
to be able to use
Android vitals to be
able to understand how are you
impacting user's batteries.
Great.
So now we've covered how you can
avoid those one-star ratings.
And as I said, we've
increased the number
of users talking about
these five-star performance
areas over the past year.
But we want it now
over the next year
to see an even larger
increase in users
talking about these things.
And so let's jump into
some of the metrics
that we have to be
able to help with that.
The Mercado Libre team,
which is behind one
the most popular e-commerce
destinations in Latin America,
if not the most
popular, was able to use
Android vitals to be
able to understand
how were their permission
requests being appreciated
by users.
And what they saw is that when
they built this new feature
into their application, they
require this permission to be
enabled, that their
permission denial
rate was much higher than
other apps in their category.
And so they worked on
redesigning their application,
and changing their
strategy for how
they requested that permission.
And as a result, they were
able to increase the users who
were able to get
access to that feature,
and reduce their
permission denial rate.
Now, the Mercado Libre team
is a pretty large team.
It's hundreds of engineers
working on it out there.
And on their application,
they have many teams
working on different parts.
And as a result, one
team introduced an issue
into the application that caused
a regression in the startup
time.
But by keeping an eye
on their Android vitals,
they were to understand that
this happened, and then work
with that team to actually
be able to debug that issue
and reduce back their startup
time to what it was previously.
Startup time is
really important.
And Android vitals
measures the startup time
from when the app is
first interactive.
Now, there's a lot of other
parts of your application
that you might
consider, and that users
might consider, to be part
of the startup as well.
And so the Lovoo team used
Android vitals and Firebase
Performance Monitoring
to be able to understand
how their performance was
throughout the whole lifecycle.
And what they found is that
their actual performance
was terrible.
So they actually rewrote
their whole sign-up and login
process, and reduced
the startup time
as reflected in vitals and
in Firebase Performance
Monitoring.
Now, I think it's important
to point out here,
why would you use Firebase
Performance Monitoring
and Android vitals?
Well where does Android
vitals get its data,
is the core question to that.
So Android vitals
is based on the data
that comes from the
Android platform itself.
And this is powered by
the hundreds of millions
of users who have opted into
sharing their data with Google,
and you, our partners.
The Firebase Performance
Monitoring tool
is based on you instrumenting
your own application,
and you then being
able to collect data
at certain points
in your application.
And it fundamentally comes
down to timers and counters
in the Firebase Performance
Monitoring tool.
And so if you want to be able to
really track these performance
pieces that are important
to getting five-star rating,
I really encourage you to use
Firebase Performance Monitoring
or another
performance monitoring
tool in your
application itself to be
able to track individual events
that you really care about.
Great.
We've covered some
case studies from
many different
stakeholders here today.
And on the top right here, you
can see some of the core people
that you would expect to
have been using performance
data historically.
Except for it was very
difficult for these people
to be able to get the
performance data in the past.
So we have an Android engineer,
head of mobile engineering,
and a product manager.
One of the things that I'm most
proud of with Android vitals
is how it's changed the
conversation around app
performance in companies.
And now we have many
stakeholders, outside
of the core engineering team
working on the application,
using performance metrics,
or, as Gavin mentioned,
these engineering metrics.
So we had quotes in
this presentation
from lead mobile product
manager, a CTO, a VP
of product, and a COO even.
And so, as we all know, quality
across the whole Android
ecosystem is improving.
And if you and your
whole entire company
are not looking at your
performance of your application
and these technical
metrics, then you're
going to be left behind.
OK, the one last
study that we did,
this just shows how
increased quality
equals increased engagement.
What we did is we
looked at games
that had users with a
really high crash rate,
and users who had a low crash
rate, across the same game.
And what we found is that users
had two and a half minutes less
engagement in the app when
they had a high crash rate.
And this trend was
even stronger for users
who had a high ANR rate.
Now, this equates to if a
user was playing your game
every single day,
to about 20 hours
a year of less engagement
time in your game.
And we all know time is money.
So really focusing on
increasing your quality
will increase the
engagement in your product.
Great.
So we're actually going to open
up for questions right now.
So I think there's
mics around if anybody
wants to ask a question.
And Gavin, you want to come
back up, and we answer?
If you put your hand up,
they'll bring a mic to you.
Yeah.
OK, no questions.
We answered them all.
Any questions?
No.
OK, great.
We're going to be around
throughout the day.
You can catch us
during the breaks.
I will also be in the
blue room at 12:30.
And you can come and
chat to us there.
There's resources
at this link here,
where you can be able to
learn more about vials,
and be able to improve
your application.
We'd like to thank
everyone that we
were able to share case
studies from today.
And we hope that you will work
on improving your application,
so that we can be able to share
case studies of your success
in our talk next year.
Thank you very much, everyone.
Thank you, [INAUDIBLE].